Master I don't think you quite realize
what you got here so why don't you just
do an 8-iron human eight possibilities
they come up to San Francisco we go in a
like a little recording studio and the
animated the director and a couple of
the animators come in the writers and we
just throw ideas and they just said try
this you need more power
Jim don't be afraid you had it all along
I never did it I am not at fault then I
said good night and then sometimes it
gets a little blue and then but I'm a
genius so that's not bad you know if we
do the other way right now and they put
in stuff I can't believe that they yeah
but they do that because I think they
have a good time kind of pushing the
boundaries of Disney Animation which is
faith number one I can't kill anybody
this is a blast I mean because to see
the second part of the equation for this
is them drawing it I mean they're so
good the guys who draw which I've made
fun of but it's actually they're so
they're really like they act with the
pencil this what they do is I kind of
give an inspiration and then they go
with it there's stuff in the cartoon
where they they just play with images
and that they go as fast as I do which
is nice but you can travel at the speed
of life what you're doing Einstein's
theory of relatives they really they
take it to the next up and they're the
ones who do the sphere on the six months
of you know the tedious tedious work but
the great thing is it's all hands on and
it's still it's a great cut it's a great
sense of comic timing they have to
[Music]
whole generation is gonna grow up
thinking use a singer I think not I
think there's two people going no man
you got no rhythm it's frightening they
should have the United Caucasian rhythm
fun you got no rhythm because if they're
but they're like Ethel Merman song so
that's why you can felt them out so
they're not they're just like old times
show business like forties musical stuff
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
you